MARK MIRCHANDANI: Now it's
time to do some job searching.
Our last video set
up companies and jobs
using the Google Cloud Talent
solution job search API.
Let's search against the
API and see what comes up.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
There's a few things we
should include in the request
when searching for jobs.
So let's cover those and
then run some searches.
For every search, we need
to provide request metadata.
This is an object that
provides information
about the user making
the search request.
It's important to provide
these details to ensure
a consistent user experience
as well as to better train
the machine learning models.
First three properties in
the object are required.
Domain should be the
domain where the search is
hosted from, such as foo.com.
Session ID and user ID are
value specific to the user doing
the search and
should properly be
obfuscated before being
provided, such as hashing them.
That way the API doesn't see
any personally identifiable
information, but
it can tell when
it's the same session and user.
Device info is
optional and consists
of the ID and type of device
so you can distinguish create
a web search and an app
search, for example.
Allow missing IDs is a Boolean
that makes those first three
fields optional.
When the API is
fully implemented,
you should always
aim to provide all
of the requested information
to ensure the best results.
You can use Allow
Missing IDs if you
can't get all the information
or if you're testing.
For our sample
code, we'll provide
some static values for these.
Technically, that's
the only required field
for doing a search.
But then the request will come
back with all sorts of jobs.
More than likely, we'll want to
actually search for something.
So we'll include a job query.
The job query can
be pretty simple
with a query string
for the actual search
terms and different filters
to help narrow down the jobs
that get returned.
For instance, you
can return only jobs
from a specific company or
filter by employment types.
We'll just stick to the
query string for now.
But there's more
information about filters
in the description below.
You can also specify
a job view property,
which is an enum that declares
how much information you
want to get back with
your job search request.
Job view full gives you back all
the information about each job
result. But you might
want to save some bytes
and choose another option
that returns less fields.
Pick the option that makes the
most sense for the platform
you're working on.
Since you may get
a lot of results,
the API will also paginate, so
you can work with a pagination
interface.
We recommend keeping the
page size to 20 or less
to avoid latency issues
and always use pagination
through the API
rather than trying
to load in all the results.
You'll get a next page
token in the response.
So if there's more
jobs, you can pass it
into the next search
queries page token.
There's also a
search mode option
that lets you choose
between a normal search
and a featured job search.
If you want to hear
more about feature jobs,
check out the previous
video in the series
that explains the
difference and when
you should use feature jobs.
There's some other
optional fields
you can read about more
in the documentation.
But let's see some
code and run a search.
Here's a sample script
that takes a search string
and then runs a search query.
We'll set up the API the top
and then we call our function.
Here's where we set
that request metadata
and grab the search
query string.
As I said before,
the request metadata
should include as much
information as possible,
but we'll still hash
the user and session
information to avoid any
personally identifiable
information.
Here we build the request
object with our search
term and our request metadata.
We're also explicitly
calling out
that this is a normal job search
instead of a feature job search
and saying we want
the full information
for each job returned.
We've also got a
page size for 20
for now, though we'd have to
use page tokens or an offset
if we wanted to get
to the next page.
With that, we'll make
the call with jobs.search
and we'll pass in our object.
Since we used job view full,
we'll get a lot of details
back.
But the code is only going to
look for two things, the title
and the search text snippet.
Each result will
return the field
that your job use specifies.
And that may be getting back
a job object for each result
as well as the fields that
are specific to the results,
such as the snippet.
Now, if we run the code
and we search for engineer,
we'll get some results in
the matching jobs field.
By default, these are
ordered from relevance
by the ML models.
You can specify the order
in the search request
if you need to do
some custom logic.
But we recommend using
the default relevance.
This is a great starting
point for getting data loaded
into the system and performing
some actual searches to see
what kind of results you get.
Looking at the raw
search response,
you'll see some important
additional information.
Total size and
estimated total size
can help you with
pagination, and matching jobs
contain the actual
search results.
In the metadata
section, you'll also
get a request ID that's unique
to this specific search.
These are globally
unique IDs generated
for that specific request.
So if you're seeing an
issue or have a question,
these requests IDs
can be very helpful
if you need to contact support.
From here, you should be
able to load information
into the job search API
and start doing searches.
In our next video,
I'll talk more
about the specifics of
relevance and ranking
for the job search results.
Thanks for watching.
And remember, when
looking for talent,
it's OK to keep your
head in the Cloud.
[MUSIC PLAYING]